well now to singer Michael Buble and we
know that he is all about love and
family so when a report claimed that
Michael said he was retiring from the
music business and he thought it was
true but I had to hear it directly from
him
there was a piece saying that you had
retired from music and I know you want
to set the record straight on that it's
been a while since I've been in the
public eye and you realize that with all
of the beautiful things that come from
being in the public eye well things that
comes along are those kind of stories
that aren't true also say we've set the
record straight I am NOT an alien even
though I know it's been said I am NOT
that's the Michael we missed it just
took some time off to be with his family
after oldest son Noah's cancer diagnosis
on Halloween of 2016 Noah's now in
remission but Michael's big comeback
album love is a reflection of that
emotional time how did you decide on the
title you know what I don't think I
could think of another word that could
express as many things as that one word
good what I was feeling what I've been
through what the music is about when I
[Music]
with the biggest reason because of what
you've been through you know I think
that what my family and I have been
through be impossible for it not to hurt
not to have an effect on everything I do
it's the truth it does what I really
wanted was a chance to UM to put
beautiful stuff back into the world
really what the world needs now is
[Music]
singing it with me I wish I just felt a
little lonely there at the end what the
world needs now is love sweet love Burt
Bacharach is sitting on a couch going to
Ching or cringing and what a man can
sing women lose their mind listen he is
the nicest guy that's the best thing and
wrote funny so talented
hi
[Music]